bei mir im studio ist jetzt bild r
experte björn spritze werden lass uns
noch mal etwas über diese amokfahrt von
dienstagnacht sprechen wir noch eine
grafik damit wir noch mal schritt für
schritt ab gehen können was genau da auf
der berliner stadtautobahn eigentlich
passiert ist die grafik jetzt haben wir
sie dann kannst du uns etwas längere
lang
nachdem nachdem er sozusagen der der
dieser 30 iraker den entschluss gefasst
hat er offensichtlich als erstes
motorradfahrer zum motorradfahrer
erfasst das bei denen sollte sich auch
um die schwerverletzten gehandelt haben
und hat dann in der folge dann versucht
weitere weitere autos schwer zu rammen
da sind dann glaube ich die leicht
verletzten wobei ich muss gestehen habe
es noch nicht genau was man das genau
zuordnen kann
da sollen aber die leicht verletzten
daraus resultieren
im prinzip muss man sagen dass das kein
todesopfer gegeben hat ist tatsächlich
auch der auswahl des des fahrers also
seines ziels glaube ich zu verdanken
also wenn er durch eine fußgängerzone
gefahren wäre wie ist ja eigentlich eher
so der der modus operandi ist von
terroristen die sich die sich mit mit
fahrzeugen versuchen einen anschlag zu
begehen dann ist er in der regel die
opferzahlen tatsächlich dann gibt es in
der regel auch tote in dem fall warum er
tatsächlich dann versucht hat er auf
andere motorisierte autos also im
straßenverkehr sozusagen auf andere
autos und motorräder
das ist nicht ganz klar aber er soll ja
auch unter psychischen problemen
gelitten haben es erinnert ein wenig an
diesem fall den wir vor einigen monaten
hatten in hessen in dem auch ein mann
mit mit einem auto versucht hat zunächst
hat es hat sie nichts autos kamen ist
dann allerdings auch hat auch passanten
gerammt und ist da ist zum glück auch
nicht tödlich ausgegangen da wurde
niemand getötet aber in der regel sind
solche solche attentate mit autos in der
regel haben den tödlichen ausgang
wenn wir jetzt schon gehört der
staatsschutz ermittelt mittlerweile
sprechen die ermittler auch über
islamistischen terror welche spuren gibt
es schon gibt es schon welche
verbindungen die man
also verbindungen dergleichen noch nicht
an wir haben es ja in von unserem
reporter kollegen gehört dass danach
eine wohnungsdurchsuchung offenbar
gegeben hat in begleitung das ist ein
mann ist von sek einheit man von
spezialeinheiten
das ist natürlich so dass die jahren der
staatsschutz bei politischer motivation
ermittelt der mann hat erwartbar gerufen
hat zumindest behauptete er eine bombe
danach auf seinem auf seinem auto noch
stehen gehabt beim hat gedroht er
springe ich an die luft werdet alle
sterben
da spricht schon einiges dafür dass der
das ja ganz offensichtlich politisch
motiviert war zum teil so dass kann
das ist ja ein schwieriger
abgrenzungsfragen wenn jemand das noch
keinen ausschließen dass keine
ausschließenden kriterien ob jemand
psychisch krankes oder eben politisch
motiviert das kann ein einander greifen
das kann das kann ja sozusagen
nebeneinander existieren oder einander
auch befeuern und insofern ich glaube
die ermittler haben dann natürlich ein
sehr starker anhaltspunkt wenn jemand
schon früher wir unsere partei kollege
gerade von den anwohnern berichtet hat
schon früher als sich aggressiv
verhalten hat an avatar gerufen hat und
dann liegt die motivation die politische
islamistische motivation relativ nahe
wir wollen jetzt noch einmal scheinen zu
meinem kollegen peter wege die frage ist
hat sich die staatsanwaltschaft schon
geäußert oder vielleicht sogar mein hat
sich die polizei oder die
staatsanwaltschaft geäußert
bevor wir damit weiter anfang erstmal
noch zu dem wohnort ihr die nachbarn
haben uns auch erzählt dass bereits vor
zwei wochen die polizei hier war und
nach samana gesucht hat warum ist immer
noch unklar
die staatsanwaltschaft und die polizei
haben jetzt eine gemeinsame mitteilung
herausgegeben darunter darin bestätigen
sie eigentlich unsere berichte und
erklären dass samantha nach bisherigem
ermittlungsstand wohl gezielt auch auf
motorradfahrer zugerast
motorradfahrer sind natürlich auf einer
autobahn ein sehr leichtes opfer und das
nicht dann auch den tod herbeizuführen
jetzt wird gegen ihn ermittelt wegen
versuchten mordes in gewahrsam und die
polizei und die staatsanwaltschaft
wollen sich gegen 13 uhr in einer
sondersendung dazu äußern
außerdem haben sie gesagt dass von einem
dass ein religiös islamistischer
hintergrund nicht auszuschließen ist
allerdings gibt es keine hinweise darauf
dass er in einer terroristischen
vereinigung mitglied gewesen ist
außerdem scheint er psychisch sehr labil
zu sein die polizei und die
staatsanwaltschaft mitgeteilt haben
13 uhr dann die pressekonferenz von der
staatsanwaltschaft berlin natürlich wie
du es gerade schon gesagt hast dann in
einer sendung sondersendung hierbei bild
zu sehen bei mir noch immer unser
terrorexperte plan stütze weil auf
facebook gab es einen post der
vielleicht schon etwas verraten hat dass
so etwas passieren könnte was genau wie
genau hat sich der amokfahrer da
geäußert
also mutmaßlich auf seinem facebook
profil gibt es gibt es zwei anträge aus
den 24 stunden vor dem anschlag in dem
ein mit gebets cup auftritt auf sein
auto deutet und der andere post
ebenfalls nochmal mit als mutmaßlich
seinem auto vor dem er posiert und ja
daran erinnert dass also erhalten
die mutige postauto ag dazu und über
palästina gesprochen dass das befreit
werden soll
und man muss dazu wissen dass diese auto
anschläge die kennen die zwei aus
jüngster vergangenheit in europa vor
allem von mitgliedern oder von
schließlich dem islamischen staat zu
reichen von terroristen die wurden aber
schon lange vorher kultiviert von
palästinensischen terroristen israel da
ist das ein sehr gängige methode gewesen
für mehrere jahre das palästinensische
terroristen auch jetzt noch versuchen
mit ihrer autos als waffen zu verwandeln
unter menschen zu überfahren passiert
jetzt in der regel noch an checkpoints
in der regel passiert es nicht mehr so
häufig in städten weil die israelischen
sicherheitsbehörden der mittlerweile
auch bauliche maßnahmen ergriffen haben
in vielen punkten also da gibt es dann
zum beispiel betonsperren vor von
bushaltestellen an exponierten orten usw
weil ich genau dieser modus operandi den
haben eigentlich in denen die
palästinensischen terroristen sehr stark
kultiviert und diese bezugnahme darauf
die die dort schon stark darauf hin dass
das also das ist eigentlich sehr
deutliche ankündigung dessen was er
vorhat